aussitôt annoncé aussitôt arrivé voici
le nouveau samsung galaxy s 21 ultras
qui est arrivé il ya quelques instants
studio je n'ai pas encore ouvert on va
se le déballer on va le regarder
ensemble on va regarder ce qu'il donne
ici dans des conditions un peu
différente vous le savez j'ai découvert
il ya quelques jours chez samsung daul
en showroom
ici c'est chez moi les conditions sont
quand même relativement différent 3 donc
prendre le temps de l'ouvrir de le
regarder ensemble de ce lot boxer et
puis d'ici quelques jours on se parlera
de sale ça ça vous parle ce sont les
nouveaux samsung galaxy boxe pro les
nouveaux petits bugs de samsung qui ont
de la réduction d'objectif feu l'air
d'être vraiment extrêmement sympa donc
s'en empare dans quelques jours vous
invite donc à venir vous abonner pour
tout savoir qui bien évidemment le test
du samsung galaxy s 21 ultras qui
arrivera aussi également dans quelques
jours ce sont plein de bonnes nouvelles
abonnez-vous comme ça vous saurez tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux d'avoir ces deux
nouveaux produits bien évidemment on va
sans parler d'ici quelques jours de cela
pour l'instant on se concentre vraiment
sur celui là le samsung galaxy s 21
ultra déjà vous le voyez la boîte est
beaucoup plus fine pourquoi parce que
vous n'avez absolument pas de blog de
charge à l'intérieur pour des questions
écologiques l'art a tendance à s'ouvrir
ça on va regarder à bien par là où c'est
beau bien là toi à ça j'aime beaucoup
on va commencer hop parce enlever ces
petits trucs qui ne servent strictement
rien et qui prennent de la place à ce
que je remarque vraiment c'est
l'épaisseur du blog ce qui fait que si
je vais le posez là j'ai un déséquilibre
qui est vraiment extrêmement prononcée
le même faire du bord ce bon vieux morse
comme à l'époque du far west
mais bon et sinon vous allez mettre une
coque de protection derrière donc ça va
venir réquilibrer l'histoire c'est vrai
qu'il est assez massif mais de notre
côté il est quand même très sympa et
personnellement voilà ça n'a pas
vraiment à me déranger et comme ça
j'aime bien cette couleur je la trouve
vraiment extrêmement élégante à
l'intérieur de la boîte puisqu'on n'a
plus le bloc des charges qu'est ce qu'on
va retrouver alors ou alors c'est ce que
ça me fait vraiment bizarre vous voyez
de ne pas trouver des blogs des charges
comme ça ça c'est vraiment très très
précieux qu'est ce que j'ai ici alors
attendez deux corps vraiment tiroirs de
cartes sim ça c'est bien évidemment
logiquement sassou leur truc là samsung
comment sa source à peut-être par là à
part là monsieur re est un boulet j'ai
donc ici de quoi venir leurs charges etc
de l'usbc usb c'est rassurez vous même
si vous n'avez plus bloc de charges vous
avez quand même de quoi venir recharger
vous pouvez donc soit acheter votre blog
de charges a pas soit les charger sur un
ordinateur vous utilisez un bloc de
charges qui va être recommandée par
votre constructeur ça c'est extrêmement
important prenait pas n'importe quoi
ne prenez pas un bloc de charges non
plus qui n'est pas adapté sans quoi vous
risquez d'endommager votre batterie fait
vraiment intense france ici je n'ai pas
d'écouteurs les écouteurs sont
obligatoires en france pensent que moi
ici j'ai une version test c'est pour ça
que je n'en ai pas mais vous vous
devriez avoir des écouteurs avec ce qui
est une obligation c'est légal donc il
voulait mettront ici ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que vous avez un dos qui
est complètement maths ça évite de
laisser des traces de doigts et je
trouve ça plutôt bien c'est assez malin
très bien réussi ça donne un côté très
très premium et surtout ce qui est très
rigolo c'est que ça vient harmoniser la
gamme puisque là vous avez modèle ultra
avec le dos en verre pour de la
recherche notamment induction mais vous
avez le samsung galaxy s 21 le tout
premier
qu'il y ait un dos en plastique on en
reparlera plus tard lors des tests ont à
peu près les mêmes effets visuels entre
le s 21 et le s 21 ultra la différence
ici c'est vous allez toucher qui
commettent beaucoup plus froid puisque
c'est un dos en verre et non pas en
plastique voilà ça il faut se le dire
par contre ce qui est bien c'est que si
vous avez un verre corning gorilla glass
vic tu ce c'est l'équivalent d'une
corning gorilla glass est qui est
présent à l'arrière mais également à
l'avant ce qui n'a vraiment venir
protéger votre smartphone est par contre
il fait quand même lui c'est 2 128 g
c'est pas de plus léger on le sent quand
même on sent vraiment le point autant
que j'aime bien vous avez incapable de
prendre d italie et 70% plus large et
qui dérouille rapidement et surtout ici
un des points forts ce smartphone c'est
son écran je voulais déjà dit lors de la
vidéo de présentation c'est du dynamic
amoled 2 x surtout un très très grand
écran de 6 8 pouces vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement 120 hertz adaptative
allègement trouvailles dans les
paramètres c'est ici côté écran fluidité
des mouvements adaptative
l'idée de ce 120 hertz adaptatif c'est
qu'il va venir choisir automatiquement
entre les différents taux de
rafraîchissement est ce qui est super
intéressant c'est que ici il va venir
choisir entre du onze hertz jusqu'à 120
hertz le 11 hertz surtout pour le all
ways and display est en train de se
télécharger plein de trucs
il fait du bruit j'ai eu plein de
l'ouvrir c'est pour ça contre les s-21
et s-21 plus vous partez de 48 heures
jusqu'à 120 hertz si vous avez une
application qui nécessitent pas du sang
vers vous allez moi consommer s'amènera
votre batterie beaucoup plus loin vous
aussi vous mettre en mode standard
si vous le souhaitez là par contre vous
aurez que de 60 hertz et la global mois
pour moi c'est vraiment vous priver de
fluidité ça ne sert strictement à rien
ou vous restez bien sûr et adaptatif
autre chose qui est assez intéressante
là dessus c'est que vous avez
effectivement une protection pour le
confort visuel un lien lutter contre la
lumière bleue ça c'est un truc qui est
vraiment important je pense à venir
active est ici c'est fait voir si je le
pousse à fond la luminosité grâce est
extrêmement lumineux ça c'est très très
très limité on va venir baisser un peu
c'est un pousse un peu trop
côté logiciel vous en parlerai une
prochaine fois mais on est sur un nuage
3.1 vous faites un double tape dessus
salle est un double tape dessus vous le
réveiller quelqu'un d'empreintes
digitales vous déverrouillez passé les
petites nouveautés logicielles mais
c'est assez marrant pourquoi pas au troc
est super intéressant ici c'est la
résolution de votre smartphone puisque
vous pouvez monter jusqu en wqs des plus
mois par défaut une famille en full hd +
moi je lui pousser ici en wqs des puces
ne pouvait cumuler le wqs des puceaux
3200 pas remis
440 s'écrit ici que noir sur blanc et en
même temps avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement 100 verte autre point
qui est sympa c'est que vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo haut parleurs
situés bien évidemment juste en bas ici
et un deuxième haut parleurs qui est
situé rue alors je dirais aussi quelques
jours dans le test ce que j'en pense je
donnerais mort pour dont je vous invite
une fois de plus à venir vous abonner
comme ça vous saurez tout il vous le
loup près absolument rien il ya un point
que j'ai vraiment hâte de découvrir en
testant justement ce nouveau samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra c'est la performance
donnée grâce au nouveau processeur
exynos 2100 j'ai commencé à regarder vos
retours vos premiers retours en
commentaire que ce soit sur youtube sur
instagram tik tok et bien il ya beaucoup
de personnes d'entre vous qui vont dire
ah non masse ce n'est pas un snapdragon
1 888 on n'a pas le dernier selon
dragons nains des casinos sa masse -
bien sûr trasim 5 sur les dernières
générations les processeurs de qualcomm
était au dessus des exigences j'ai
vraiment par contre hâte de voir ce que
ça va donner sur ce nouveau produit
puisque les promesses qui sont faites
sur ce nouveau processeur exynos 2100 on
va être extrêmement intéressant très
alléchante
en plus de ça il est épaulé avec soit 12
il ya drame soit 16 giga de ram sur le
modèle ultra il faut savoir que sur les
21 et s-21 plus vous avez 8 gigas de ram
ce qui est déjà très très bien mais là
on est quand même deux crans au dessus
12 ou 16 giga de ram alors attention
vous avez deux config en 12 il ya drame
vous avez soit 128 soit 256 giga de
stockage pour avoir le 16 giga de ram et
bien il faudra choisir la version la
plus chère avec 512 giga de stockage
à noter ici que vous avez aussi la plus
grosse batterie on a un écran qui est un
peu plus grand par rapport au reste 20
en plus on à 0,1 pouce de différence ici
vous avez une batterie de 5000
milliampères heures et c'est ça qui est
assez intéressant cette année c'est que
vous voyez je voulais dit je vous le
redis ici c'est que on a une boîte qui
pas très épaisse c'était déjà le cas
l'année dernière avec apple avec les
iphone 12 du fait que vous n'ayez plus
le blog de charge à l'intérieur on va
forcément gagner en taille de bois tu
sais pas si on gagne en tout cas on perd
un accessoire et à l'intérieur ça ça m'a
toujours fait rire les l'année dernière
lorsque j'en parlais avec apple j'en
parle bien évidemment si ça me fait
toujours un peu râlé je me suis habitué
à l'idée de me dire
ok que maintenant on aurait plus de
blocs de charges l'intérieur on va
pouvoir utiliser soit les blocs de
charge les années précédentes soit
acheté le blog de charges en plus tout
ça dans une idée éco-responsable ça ne
sert à rien d'avoir plein de bugs de
charges qu'on n'utilise plus et qu'on
jette quelque part où je ne sais pas ce
qu'on en fait qui dorment dans les
placards alors vous pouvez les utiliser
sur les modèles des années ultérieures
et quant à la vitesse de charges vous
êtes ici sur une charge 25 watts maximum
il faut savoir qu'il vaut mieux charger
ses batteries un peu plus lentement pour
ne pas les endommager 25 quads ça reste
de la recharge rapide
on sent parlera également d'ici quelques
jours dans le test mais pour moi ici
absolument rien de choquant et ensuite
une des parties qui nous intéresse le
plus c'est la partie photo et vidéo
puisque c'est samsung galaxy s 21 sont
vraiment axé sur la photo et la vidéo
alors vous le voyez ici vous avez
plusieurs capteurs ou essayer de voir à
quoi il sert tous vous avez la même
configuration en termes de mégapixels et
en termes d'ouverture que ce qu'on avait
les dernières avec le samsung galaxy s
20 ultra par contre ici on a de nouveaux
capteurs donc une fois de plus on verra
le résultat dans le test en ici c'est
votre ultra-grand-angle c'est un 12
mégapixels vous avez en dessous juste
ici le grand temps que c'est votre
capteur principal c'est le sens 8
mégapixels juste là est juste là vous
avez deux téléobjectifs dans les deux
cas on a 10 mégapixels celui que vous
avez sur la partie de droite
et bien c'est un téléobjectif avec un
zoom optique x 3 tandis qu'en dessous
vous avez un zoom périscopique avec zoom
optique x 10 et jusqu'à fois sans grâce
au space zoomer c'est que depuis son
virage très très bientôt
tandis qu'au dessus là vous le voyez
juste là ça si un laser qui va servir
notamment pour le mode portrait et
également pour l'auto focus qui vous
permettra d'avoir un excellente
autofocus très rapide en conditions de
faible luminosité ça on en verra
également lors du test et vous le voyez
si vous avez un petit flash led tandis
qu'à l'avant et planck est juste là vous
avez une caméra de cette fille de 40
mégapixels j'aurais aimé cette année que
ça me saoule nous met une caméras
planquées sous l'écran on l'a vu l'autre
jour avec sceptre la technologie existe
à l'ipp pas encore super abouti
j'espérais qu'en 2021 samsung le fasse
il travaille dessus mais ça sera a
priori plus tôt pour l'année prochaine
on verra en tout cas il ya des modèles
qui peuvent sortir peut-être la gamme
d'autres on va garder espoir pour 2021
ce qui va nous intéresser ici d'un point
de vue logiciel c'est qu'on a pas mal de
nouveautés [ __ ] attendait tac différentes
nouveautés des gens dans le space zoom
jusqu'à fois sans bon ici il n'y a pas
grand chose à lui recherché que space
zoom sur ma table donc ça sert
strictement à rien mais surtout ce qui
nous intéressait dans la plus on
a notamment c'est ce qu'ils appellent la
vue du réalisateur ça je voulais déjà
montré l'autre jour vous avez la caméra
de celui-ci en picture in picture
donc ça vous sortira un seul fichier
vidéo vous avez en plus ici votre
ultra-grand-angle téléobjectif 1 et vous
avez le téléobjectif 2 dont vous allez
choisir ce que vous allez pouvoir avoir
ici à voir si c'est vraiment intéressant
et s'il ya vraiment des visages on verra
ça également une prochaine fois au truc
qui est assez intéressant et je vous le
montrera également lors du test c'est le
mode single take c'est la nouvelle
version du mode single take on se le
regardera également vous avez un mode
single take de 10 secondes on peut
monter jusqu'à 15 secondes et 5 secondes
minimale et surtout ce qui est aussi
très intéressant c'est en vidéo vous
pouvez venir filmer ses marques et ici
jusqu'à huit cas à 24 images par
secondes et vous pouvez filmer partout
sinon toutes les autres caméras en 4k à
60 images par seconde que ce soit sur le
téléobjectif sur l' ultra grand-angle
enfin comme vous voulez donc ça c'est
plutôt une bonne idée sans oublier de la
vidéo super stabiliser peut filmer jusqu
en 60 images par seconde beaucoup
d'entre vous en sierra leone sur le fait
qu'il n'y a plus de port micro sd pour
venir stocker vos photos qu'on avait
beaucoup dit et bien écoute monsieur
greu moi j'ai beaucoup de photos que
j'ai dans ma carte microsd ça me fait
râler de plus en avoir de nouveau ravi
dans le cloud surtout quand on sait que
google va diminuer la partie gratuite du
stockage dans le cloud clairement
aujourd'hui les marques veulent que vous
payez du stockage pour payer votre parc
de serveurs autant à une époque on était
illimité sur google photos ou temps
aujourd'hui c'est plus trop le cas alors
les premiers abonnements coûte pas très
cher mais si comme moi vous fait plein
de photos et que vous vous retrouvez à
avoir des doublures de photos ça peut
vous coûter rapidement cher il faut donc
vraiment veiller à ces photos à parvenir
à ce conte avec de l'argentique avant
ouvert uniquement 24 photos dans sa
pellicule c'est pas le cas vous pouvez
quand même à en faire beaucoup
néanmoins avec ses nouveaux smartphones
mais bien vous n'avez pas toutes à boire
c'est pour ça qu'il faut vraiment
pouvoir se poser la question dès le
départ de la configuration qu'on veut
acheter déjà 128 go de stockage
vous avez de quoi faire maintenant posez
vous la question de votre usage
aujourd'hui du nombre de photos vous
allez faire parle de photos m'ont parlé
également de films que vous téléchargez
part également de musique dans posez
vous la question de votre consommation
globale sur cette année 2021 mais
également potentiellement sur 2022
ouah 2023 puisque c'est un smartphone
que vous allez pouvoir garder trois ans
sans aucun problème ici en plus de
villes techno qui est assez intéressante
c'est du wifi 6e c'est un peu un wifi 6
améliorée c'est en tout cas la dernière
techno de wifi 6 qui accordent pour ici
dans ce mondial puisque c'est l'ultra
puisqu'on à ce qui ce fait de mieux et
ça c'est bien vous avez également de
l'ultra wide band une double carte sim
est un smartphone qui est certifié ip 68
je dirais que c'est aujourd'hui le grand
minimum sur des smartphones a plu 2011
sans oublier bien évidemment samsung ex
pour transformer votre smartphone en un
ordinateur
j'aime bien la prison d'ain je trouve
plutôt bonne alors c'est vrai que c'est
un très très grand smartphone il ya un
moment où vous allez devoir venir
l'utiliser à demain parce que demain
vous allez un petit peu galéré mais
j'aime bien format il faut aimer les
grands smartphones il faut aimer ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque les fables est
les 6 8 pouces c'est énorme on est
quasiment 7 pouces
on n'a pas encore franchi le cap méchant
ça sera pour très très très très bientôt
les smartphones s'allonge pour du
contenu multimédia ses instances pour me
regarder des séries des films comme ça
c'est un sens c'est plutôt pas mal pour
apprendre en classique des boutons de
volume bouton pour allumer votre tiroir
de cartes sim qui est planqué juste ici
avec une double sim ça c'est plutôt
sympa laissez-moi enlever les plastiques
laissez moi le préparer complètement et
on en reparle lors du test d'ici
quelques jours puisque je peux vous
assurer que là dessus il ya beaucoup de
choses à raconter
on a donc 3 config trois tarifs
différents je voulais déjà cité le nom
reste à faire quand même ici pour bien
se remettre un mémoire sur la version 12
iliad ram 128 go de stockage vous êtes à
1259 euros soit la rassure 12 igad ram
256 go de stockage 1309 euro et sur la
version 16 giga de ram qui montre les
muscles avec 512 jia de stockage 1409
euros dites-moi est-ce que ce samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra pourrait vous
intéresser si oui quelle config quel
point négatif vous avez relevé j'ai noté
l'absence d'une drogue des charges qui
note également l'absence de port microsd
maintenant dites moi vous si vous avez
noté d'autres points qui vous semblerait
être plutôt négatif et surtout qu'est ce
que vous aimez et pourquoi est ce que
vous pourriez potentiellement allez vous
positionner dans ce nouveau samsung
galaxy s2 d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse
vous amis les liens en bas dans la
description de ce rendez vous très très
très très très très très très vite pour
parler de ce smartphone vous dévorer le
test est bien évidemment parler
également des samsung galaxy note pro et
ça c'est super